Dena started her own business over two years ago
and is looking to take her delicious desserts
to the next level.
You must know that they are "50 First Dates" inspired
and she has done this with her husband and her daughter.
It's a family affair.
And before the break
you said your ultimate goal was to, I don't know
maybe get a food truck, maybe a brick and mortar.
We have Ludo and Jeffrey here who better to ask
than the two top chefs, you know, on the globe.
What was your advice?
With the food truck, be careful you need storage.
I mean, I think, you know the space you need,
you know in your kitchen.
So by the food truck, you need to use
all the little space in the truck to be very smart,
the way you build your line.
And I recommend you to really hire somebody
to help you to do that, definitely.
And think about A to Z, how to operate the line, definitely.
A couple of things I would actually,
we talked about when we were on break,
but I think you need a partner
and not a partner that probably tell you how to cook,
but a partner to help you with finance,
do the books so you don't have to think about anything
except how many cakes I have to sell?
How many a month? what I can do.
So that headache, that stress of money is terrible,
you don't want that stress,
it's there whether you like it or not.
So I would get a partner.
And the most important thing, your cup cake is delicious.
So you're gonna be busy for sure, for sure.
You're gonna be so busy.
Thank you.
And we'd like to help you get started,
and that's why Blue Diamond Almond Breeze
is going to give you $15,000.
(audience clapping and cheering)
To help you get started.
Thanks guys.
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
I mean.
That's cool.
Do you need a driver?
Two days a week, right?
I'm available.
In Hawaii? I would drive in Hawaii, yeah.
That would be fun.
I mean, you really do have a strong story here.
The Hawaii connection, the "50 First Dates",
this crown is very identifiable.
I'm not kidding, I wouldn't forget it
and I would know it anywhere.
So although many people in Hawaii wear it
this can be literally your crown and identifier.
(audience clapping)
And your story of your husband and your daughter
and "50 First Dates", good luck.
We can't wait to follow you on your journey
and Jeffrey and Ludo like.
(Drew screaming)
(upbeat music)